all right marissa
is with us marissa is in palm beach
florida hi marissa how are you
hi dave hi chris thanks for taking my
call i'm good
good how can we help um so i
my biggest goal really is to purchase a
home before i turn 30
i'm on baby step two i make about 72 000
a year
and my debt right now after working on
baby step 2
is and 112 thousand in student loans i
have a
um tsp with uh the government matched at
a five percent for a total of ten
percent match
um i previously spoke with a previous
employer i had
about um rolling over my old 401k
so i kind of want your opinion on how
i should move forward i will be getting
married by the end of the year and kind
of just want to know what to do with
those 401k funds
or just finish paying my debt before i
purchase a home ah
wow so you're on the cusp of doing a lot
of stuff
you're looking and life's ahead of you
and you're trying to make decisions and
lay out
a game plan and marissa i'll tell you
this
i want you to make two-year decisions
young lady that is look out ahead make
some decisions
that you're going to look back on in two
years from now you're going to be
grateful you made them
and that first and foremost will be
cleaning up this debt
and i know you have this desire to own a
home and i have no doubt that you will
uh but when you do it ahead of schedule
it can end up more of a curse than a
blessing
so slow down get intentional let's crack
out the student loan debt
uh be intentional even with the wedding
you all have coming up
save pay cash for that thing and then
gain alignment together as you all are
working to continue paying off debt
renting somewhere for a year or two is
not a sin i've looked at it
uh how old are you i'm 28.
okay and um when are you getting married
um by the end of the year i'm in florida
now
what's his financial what's his
financial condition
um so we met in grad school where both
social workers for the government um he
makes a little bit less than i do maybe
about
60 000 and he did purchase a
home where his mom lives in in louisiana
with a conventional loan
um and he got hurt in an accident and
got
a settlement from that so he's pretty
okay financially
is he so he's debt-free other than his
mom's home
and i think maybe like uh 30 000 in
student loans
okay so let's say we're combined
that makes you having a hundred and ten
hundred twenty thousand dollar your
income
and you've got uh you said you had 110
in student loans and he has 30. did i
hear that right
correct okay uh unless is there
does he have a pile of money and from
that settlement still laying around
i believe he does he did set um i think
maybe about 25 000 to fight in one
bank account i mean i think he has other
funds from okay so unless i start
hearing something else in the math which
i haven't heard yet
that there's missing maybe there's
information i don't have i don't think
you're gonna own a home when you're 30.
okay and that's what i wanted to call
yeah
because you've got a hundred and uh
forty thousand dollars to clean up with
a hundred and ten thousand dollar income
married
and twenty five thousand in the bank
account that you can throw at it so you
just can't quite get there
in in in six months or a year and that's
really about all you got left after you
get married right
correct so you're going to make it by
you're going to make it but it's going
to be 32 or 31.
okay but when you do it you'll have zero
debt
you'll have your emergency fund in place
you do not cash out 401ks unless it
or old 401ks even unless it's to avoid a
bankruptcy or foreclosure
and because the government's going to
take all
take taxes out of it right now there's
no penalty normally there's a 10
penalty too but um they're going to take
taxes out of it too and so that's going
to be like borrowing money at 30
interest to get out of debt you don't
want to do that so roll your old 401
case to iras get with smart investor
pros and do that
and then we're going to give you a
wedding gift we want you to get get into
ramsay plus
and go through financial peace
university and start using the every
dollar budget
and you guys start working together as
part of your pre-marriage counseling
and getting ready to be married not
combining your finances until you're
married but working together and
learning and hitting these goals and
and saying okay then when as soon as you
do combine households
then you put it into high gear and knock
this stuff out and i think you're going
to have a house in
31 32 years old within three years but i
don't think you're gonna have one if you
do it smart
right within uh by the time you're 30.
no i agree dave
and i want to clarify for everyone out
there i know the government the cares
act has said that you can get to your
401k
and they've gotten rid of the 10 penalty
they did not get rid of the obligation
to pay income taxes on the money that
you pull out so i don't care about the
cares act
i care about your financial future
you've got two reasons that you would
touch that money
to stave off a bankruptcy or to prevent
a foreclosure
those are the only two reasons did you
just say you don't care about the
characters i sure did
i don't care about cares don't care
about it